you don't realize I got stopped doing I
gotta stop approaching women with this
move right here apparently you do that
to a policewoman she does not find it
funny at all I don't know I was just you
know give you a I love you
Oh what is going on YouTube now I am
excited about this for a long time
because in all honesty I don't know
anything about the [ __ ] now what about
talking about you class I don't know
what it's like to pluck or shave your
eyebrows but in all honesty this [ __ ] is
getting out of hand I know you have been
thinking about this too so I'm still
saying what the [ __ ] is going on with
the eyebrow epidemic that's right
epidemic some of y'all have forgotten
what eyebrows look like and get mad at
us what we get surprising [ __ ] we don't
know what the [ __ ] were looking at so
it's been a while but you already know
what it is everything let's get it left
out there's a few things you need to
know if you [ __ ] up your eyebrows
listen if your eyebrows look like a
question mark get done [ __ ] up that
means even your eyebrows don't even know
what the [ __ ] they are how you look up
to what she wants on your face and
expect people take you seriously huh
that means your eyebrows aren't
questionable that means you always look
like you got a question on your face
literally that means nobody wants to ask
you for directions because you always
look confused
some of you out there have even pluck
your eyebrows to death that's right not
death due death because you didn't
listen when we told you to stop getting
mad other people that don't got their
balls cuz out all you've got left unlike
fresh fans and a big-ass boy what the
hell you gonna do with that you ever see
that girl who's plucked her eyebrows so
much she forgot what they were supposed
to be [ __ ] every day her eyebrows aren't
a new spot on the face they are doing a
deal technician like on Google Maps or
something because every time is like pin
the tail on my [ __ ] donkey mmm
I get it listen [ __ ] in one eyebrow be
six inches taller than the other one hmm
why your other eyebrow you like is
flying away from your goddamn face you
do realize that when only one eyebrow is
raised all the time you just skeptical
about everything baby what you think
about the shirt I like it [ __ ] you
always look skeptical as [ __ ] with your
goddamn up god damn it you got to stop
driving your eyebrows so high you know
what you look like you always look like
you are constantly surprised imma get me
some
your friends and family feel about that
[ __ ] I'll bet you they stressed out as
[ __ ] because every time they look at
your face they need shits going down
Jenny what's wrong oh wait nevermind
goddamn is your eyebrows will get butter
[ __ ] get another thing honey gonna draw
your eyebrows we've got a single curve
in it go you know your eyebrows are
supposed to carve a certain way they
ain't - Bobby's moles do with those
eyebrows huh guess your emotions tell
you wanna give me the best poker player
on earth ain't nobody know what the [ __ ]
you feeling you know what your brother
like y'all Rob would like a pair of
broken dreams Vanessa's a mouth why are
they so got their dick and I'm not
talking about the naturally thick
eyebrows no don't know what God gave me
you can work that [ __ ] to death in the
fine as hell
I'll talk about the ones that don't know
when to stop because at a certain point
when you were drawn a [ __ ] in you look
at the mirror saying no not thick enough
[ __ ]
yes thick enough you look like you got
in a fight with the sharpie and lost
looking like two pieces of tree bun on
your goddamn face and with all the stuff
- of course if you love doing your
eyebrows that way I'm not one to judge
and tell you what the [ __ ] to do with
your body
[ __ ] me I don't have any say in what you
do I have a personal premise for
eyebrows you have a personal premise for
your eyebrows go ahead do you think mama
but don't get mad when people question
what the [ __ ] you going but don't get
mad at me when I look at your eyebrows
and I react with hi I'm Tami oh hey nice
to meet you Alma go don't get mad at me
because I can't trust a girl who don't
even remember where her eyebrows begin
and and some of y'all be starting here
and ending at the back of your neck good
yeah I brows are like looking directly
into the Sun you want to look at it but
you know it's gonna burn the [ __ ] out
your eyes oh why is going on YouTube
couple actually a vlog topic that was
suggested by a lot of you won this one
it was quite a few so uh yeah thank you
for hope you guys enjoyed it I don't
know but once again if you guys want to
come again you guys already know go for
broke apparel calm and Buddy fat bit
we'll be back this Wednesday
with new tips and a lot more funny [ __ ]
even if you don't want to get fit the
videos are still entertaining as [ __ ]
watching anyway
some of you guys want more different
vlog topics or articles that you want me
to talk about make sure you go to the
fanpage suggest it over there write me a
personal message so I can read that or
just write it on the fake you know the
page yourself mmm so I will see you guys
Wednesday and also Sunday I might come
out with the skin hopefully it's done by
then if not then you guys get another
vlog but the sketch is gonna be tight
trust me trust me trust me what for a
long time now because uh uh uh oops
sushi there have even prep have even
propped even the prompt I got about
today hmm
[ __ ] you always acceptable acceptable
you do realize that all that stop
laughing at your own [ __ ] look okay